Film Courage: Since [your book] Writing for
the Green Light which was published in 2014
or …?
Scott Kirkpatrick: 2015.
Film Courage: 2015…okay.
Has your personal opinion wavered on anything
in the book that you were maybe more dogmatic
about and then since [such as] a new film
has come out or some thing has shifted, you’ve
actually changed your opinion?
Scott Kirkpatrick: No.
I mean only in the sense that when you’re
writing a book…you know…if it were a blog
or something else, you can be a little bit
more like this is what is working today and
right now.
I wrote that book and the book I am working
on also about distribution, I focus on principles,
not rules, not gimmicks, not trends, principles.
Think about engineering for instance.
We sent human beings to the moon and we returned
them to the earth with as much computing power
on board as 4-function calculator.
People were using slide rulers at NASA to
calculate how are we going to land an object
on the moon.
So you think technology today is going to
send us to wherever and all these other things.
The truth is the principles that work in technology
today in an engineering level are exactly
the same as they were in the 60’s, just
different tools to get to the same result.
Writing for the Green Light is the same idea.
If you are trying to be a writer, if you are
trying to build your career as a writer, there
are certain tools that you have in your tool
kit that are going to propel you and there
are others that are just going to hold you
back.
Those Goldmine Genres that I wrote about in
the book are as true today as they were in
the 60’s, as they were in the 40’s, as
they will be 30 years from now.
You know, Sharknado is a great example of
a creature feature.
You see women in peril thrillers all the time
on TV, you see them all over the world.
Action movies with aging stars have been here
from the beginning of the B-movie, as the
second-tier to the major one.
And they are going to continue no matter what.
They were big in the 80’s and the 90’s
because of video rentals and now they are
big today because of VOD opportunities.
These are just core value content pieces that
every company looks for in one capacity or
another.
It’s as true as it was written a few years
ago as it will be in the future.
And because it’s a book, I really focus
on the stuff that is going to stick around.